Oh
how's it going welcome back to my video
on code Tekken tutorials my name is Matt
it is really early in the morning so
sorry I'm slurring a little bit I'm
still waking up but I just wanted to go
ahead and finish this it was on my mind
last night I had started this new CPP
for school labs thing and basically I
was just gonna go through all these labs
starting from the beginning and I think
this will make kind of a nice little
series to just go through all these from
start to finish
explain everything and that should maybe
help people get into C++ so we're on the
very first one sale so if you want to
follow along and learn now it's good
timing if you want to wait till a little
later when things are a little bit more
difficult and advanced if this stuff is
too easy for you then consider maybe
subscribing and checking back later when
the series is further along I'm gonna
try to do these as often as I can manage
so we did the first five in the last
video and they were pretty
straightforward but it looks like now
we're getting into a few more things I
just want to knock out six seven and
eight and we're gonna do the same thing
here I'm just gonna open visual studio
code on this bars set one folder with
this command and cygwin so I'm using the
command line cygwin which is basically a
linux turnable terminal on windows and
it's spelled cy g wi n in case you want
to go look it up and grab yourself
that's kind of a separate thing alright
so v is done and we want to look at six
and the question here is let's see write
a program which accepts a character and
displays it as its ASCII very valued by
an integer number here we go
and the reason why is because a
character is eight different bits or as
a binary bit in a computer you can you
can signify every character so like the
number eight for example it looks like
this in binary and then we go to the
characters and we'll find
got all these symbols like the letters
of the alphabet a capital T for example
is this and the ASCII code is 84 so to
do over in tinning or what it's talking
about here and you know what I'm just
going to I'm just going to comment out
these old prompts because we don't want
about a bunch of prompts stopping us
from doing what we're doing so there we
go those are all all the old ones are
commented out and I'm not gonna make the
mistake I made last video and I'm
actually gonna have a little bit of a
wider screen this time there we go
need more screen real estate they
never-ending problem of being a coder
maybe I can do it like this
that's not too bad actually I don't mind
that get out of here cookies button got
it ok so there's some ASCII codes let's
go back to this write a program which
accepts a character and displays its
ASCII better about you almost variable
so we're gonna need a character for the
input and we'll just call this answer
and then we're going to need to see in
it so of course CNS consul and let's do
a console out first here and just let
the user know what's going on that's
always a good idea that way they're not
just totally lost when a prompt comes up
so this will say character to ASCII
Translate translator and then a new line
and then enter a character and then it
will prompt after that so we need to
store the character so we're gonna go
ahead make that and then we'll do a CN
of this answer so that'll sit there
until the user presses a key and press
ENTER and what we're gonna do is take
this answer and just print it out as its
ASCII value and to do that there's a
couple different ways
let's do a new line here and we'll say
that's a new line a little quote symbol
which we must put a backslash in front
of so it doesn't recognize it as a
different character and then this
variable and then we'll finish that it's
going to be surrounded by this little
single quote and then no space is
ASCII value and then we'll print the
ASCII value of the whole thing there we
go
I'll use this and to print the ASCII
value we basically need to cast this
character as an integer so what that
means is well if you look at this
decimal number
well integers integers also have a a
binary setup looks like I can't see we
can't see the rest of this here we go
so integers also have a binary number
because they're they're eight bits wide
as well just like characters so you
could take the memory that is stored as
a character and say okay what's well if
that were an integer what would it be so
that's basically what this whole symbol
this whole thing is is just because
characters and integers have the same
width that might not be true for all
compilers so take that with a grain of
salt but and check your compilers
details if you're not entirely sure so
basically the old style is to just do
this when parentheses end and then right
after it the variable and that will cast
it to an integer and spit it out there
and that should give us the right answer
but if this isn't this this is like I
said the old C way I'll show you the C++
way let's go ahead and run this and just
confirm that it works so we're gonna do
our little make run command I find it
g plus plus name dot CPP and ei dot exe
okay so that'll compile it and then run
it and our character it was pressed to
character P enter these ASCII value is
112 let's confirm we'll find the number
112 and that looks like that's HTML
symbol
we want this one there we go yeah it's
all our case be so there we go that is
correct
now the new way of doing this for using
C++ and don't want to use the old C
stuff is you do a static cast it has an
integer like so and then you put the
variable in parenthesis like that so
this is the newer way of doing it I
guess it's a little safer and like I say
too much about it but that's you'll see
it both ways basically this would be
again and we get the same thing so I'd
recommend if you're using C++ in general
to do this static cast method it's a
little more verbose but it's also there
are advantages to am I gonna get into
that too much let's just continue if you
want to look at more about it do look
into static cast something you can
google and people really want I could
talk more about it but we'll move on for
now so let's go on to seven I'm trying
to keep these 20 minutes so I'd like to
get all these knocked out I think I've
done enough preamble and I just could
talk and write approach and I can just
continue write a program that swaps the
value of two variables easy okay so
let's get a C out swap two variables so
just letting the user know what's going
on and we're going to ask for VAR one
and then we'll declare two variables now
it doesn't say what kind of variables
whether the characters integers whatever
we're going to do them as strings string
bar one and strings are part of the
standard we'll just have to include
string up here
it's basically an array of characters so
there are other ways to do this or we
could do this with numbers but we're
just I'm just going to do this bar one
will do also do bar to I'll go ahead and
just declare both there we're at it and
we're going to do a CN bar one
and then we're going to prompt for bar
two here and we're gonna need a new line
because otherwise it's going to be up
here all jumbled together and we'll do a
standard CN bar - and then what we're
gonna do is we're just gonna swap the
values so the way to do this is you
basically well there's some ways with
moving it around memory that can be more
efficient but the most straightforward
way is to basically make a third bar
just called like temp or something or
holder I'll just call it T holder and
basically what you do is you say okay
well we want to swap these so Leona or
two to be var1 and of our one to be bar
- so something's got to be in the middle
holding now why what's going on what's
going on okay we'll just prepare the
output here swapped r1 it is now and
will save our r1 here and that with a
new line and we'll do the same thing
with bar - so it just spits out the in
there so this little section right here
which I will scope that way this temp
doesn't stay stay in scope after doing
this whole work and basically what we're
gonna do is use well T holder is now
going to equal var1 and since bar 1 is
now being held we can assign bar 1 or
whatever bar 2 is and lar 2 is now going
to equal whatever bar you want used to
be which is now held and that T holder
and boom we've done a swap is that easy
and as this goes out of scope this T
holder will deconstruct and no longer
exists but of course bar 1 and V 2 still
will exist and be swapped so as we go
down here these should now be correct
let's go ahead and run this same command
so I'll press up there we go and swap
two variables variable 1 we can type in
any string we'll I'll just put my
Matt and var - yeah I'm gonna put cool
not saying I'm cool but I am and now we
swap them so bar one became cool and bar
two became Matt and boom there we go
so we swapped there is an algorithm for
swap so there is like include swap and
like so I think there might be in
something else is it a memory I don't
know it's in one of them anyways I don't
want to go down that rabbit hole right
now but basically there are some
built-in functions you can use to do
this automatically - if you not sure how
to write here your own for the
particular variable you're using if
you're using your own class or something
you got to write it yourself so there's
that but hopefully that is enough to
help you get started let's see eight
write a program to calculate the area of
a circle area of a circle is of course
PI R squared
yeah times R squared so it'll look
something like this
oldest a/c out calculate the area of a
circle so that way we know what we're
doing and basically you won't just want
to get the radius and you can take it
from there
so you want to do a float for the radius
and then we'll just prompt for it so
we'll say C out enter the radius if I
can spell dope so my ball in there at
the end and then a cien radius so there
we can enter a float for that and then
we can just calculate it in sir the
answer and say something like radius of
your
Circle our wait let's see the sorry the
area of your circle is and we'll just
spit it out right here keeps doing that
keeps it keeps adding two quotations
when I try to end the quotations that's
driving me crazy and then we can just do
the formula in line here which is going
to be radius
times and then we want to do all right
well we want pie 3.14 it's going to be
close enough there's a PI constant
I think it's M underscore PI but we
don't see it unless we import I believe
it's math and for include math see math
see math and does that show up now no so
I don't remember where it's at it's in
one of these headers I could probably
find out the quick Google search M PI
and C++ voila it's defined in math dot H
no no someone else corrected use math
finds and then okay so we could also do
a hash define or we could do the other
ways of doing it whatever let's just put
a 3.14 in here so basically we could
declare it ahead of time
somehow or from one of these headers but
it's just the number pi so however you
want to get it just just do that that's
fine so we do the radius times the
radius of course four squared
there's also from the mount math header
I believe it's power but of course
squared is just radiant is just the same
thing times itself so we'll put those in
inner parentheses that way that it
calculates the radius first as we intend
and let's put a new line here at the end
new line character and there we go well
that should get us the radius so let me
go ahead and compile and run that all
right enter the radius so we have a
radius of five so we get the area of 78
which of course is five times five times
pi
and there we go so that should be the
correct radius let's go ahead and knock
these last two out number 9 what is
going on here is write a program to
check whether a given number is positive
or negative using a ternary operator so
the terminal operator is a way of doing
if-else and this is really really really
odd for them to ask this here because
flow control is in the next set so
they're asking and set one on number
nine for us to do flow control when flow
control is part two what stop just what
I don't understand tutorials who do crap
like this like do something before we
teach you how to do it good luck anyway
okay so what's positive or negative so
and we'll just to see out enter a number
and then we'll do float some number
number one standard CN number one and
then we're going to use the ternary
operator here to spit out whether it's
positive or negative and we'll say
number we need the variable here number
one is open your space and here is where
the ternary operator comes in so we
wanted this to say positive is positive
negative that's negative so we need in
parentheses our condition that does a
check so if we say number one is less
than zero for example then we're gonna
say it's negative so will spit out
negative and otherwise hope we use this
and so if it's not less than zero if it
ends up being greater or equal to zero
we will say the word positive
and there we go and then we'll just go
ahead and throw a newline character at
the end here so this whole section right
here is the ternary operator it wasn't
not like about this oh I need more to it
you
super turns negative or returns oh I'm
sorry I got these mixed up I think do I
know I don't let's do a zero dot F there
and we might have to do this a different
way it doesn't look like it's gonna like
it let me just
well maybe I have to have the entire
thing in parenthesis I think I do yeah
in this case having it in line like this
I'm gonna have to have the entire thing
in parenthesis and I forgot to do a new
line right here so that's why those are
jumbled together so enter a number let's
do it negative five and it says negative
five is negative
let's run it again and this time we'll
enter a normal five and it will say five
is positive okay so that was a little
trip up I just needed to surround the
entire thing in parenthesis but as you
can see it's the condition if the
condition is true it returns the first
thing otherwise it returns the second
thing so that's how you do those ternary
operators and it looks like we want one
more to check for even and odd using a
ternary operator so I'm just going to
duplicate all this code right below and
comment out the old stuff here and this
is numero ten so and this is going to be
an even or odd set so enter a number
number one and one of the things we can
do here in case we uncomment them all
and try to run them all is just scope
this one that way we don't see number
one number one
since we're repeating a variable if
one's in a different scope then they
won't complain so that way we could
actually actually do both of them like
this and see there's no underlining
errors but if we took this scope out
then it's going to have this weird error
where all you did you're declaring the
same variable twice and of course the
compiler won't like that one bit so
there we'll just throw a scope there so
I'll do it and that's just kind of a
little side thing okay so even or odd
we're essentially going to do the same
thing except we want to say
we want to use a modulo so if number one
modular
two is equal to zero then it is even
otherwise it's odd or am I not doing
right about this
and - oh these are floats floats aren't
so easy to do with even and odd so we're
gonna do integers here just whole
numbers so maybe we'll rename this yeah
that's fine so this is got to be a whole
number of course - even or odd and there
we go
so basically what this does is it's a
modulo it divides by two and sees what's
left over as it keeps dividing by two so
if it's odd
it'll we end up equaling one and go to
the second case and say hard and if it's
zero it'll say even so that should just
work and we'll be done here so I'm gonna
go ahead and run this even or odd enter
a number let's say 95 and it says 95 is
odd we'll do it again and this time
we'll say 96 96 is even very good so
thank you for watching this video and
for following along hopefully this helps
you get into C++ and learn some of the
basics of how these initial laps work
I'll see you guys in the next video
peace out keep coding and did what you
can to love life it's crazy world out
there and it's up to us to make the
world a better place so I just remember
that odd thing I'm throwing in at the
end of this video peace out guys